[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome once again to I'd like
to know our Bible question and answer
program here at some TV and we are so
very pleased that you have chosen to
join us for this particular study thank
you for being with us and we pray that
it will be a blessing to you and to
those that you have the privilege of
sharing the good news of Christ coming
with I'm in the company of two uh men of
Distinction to my left or run to Maria
to my left Pastor Stephen Bohr the
president and uh founder and speaker
here at some TV and secrets unsealed
Pastor is always great to be here with
you thank you CA good to be with you too
and to my right uh Pastor Daniel Miranda
uh
the younger of the of the group uh by a
little bit Pastor is always good to
study the word of God with you thank you
it is a pleasure for me to be here in
this program as well amen these men are
students of the word and we always have
a good time studying uh the word of God
together and sharing so this program has
become one of our favorites and from the
emails the contacts that we are
receiving we know that it is a favorite
of yours also so again thank you for
joining us today
um should you like to be part of this
experience would you like to get in on
the fun as it were you can do so by
emailing us at TV at some
tv.org that is TV at
suntv.org some TV is
s-u-m-tv.org and we will add your
question to this rather impressive stack
of questions that we have before you we
uh ask for your patience we're getting
through them and getting to them just as
fast as we possibly can but we don't
like to rush too much to the questions
because uh these questions be speak
what's on your heart and we want to give
do deference to your questions and
answer them as thoroughly as we possibly
can from the word of God so we don't try
to rush through we try to be as thorough
as we can which means uh we don't get
through many many questions per show but
we'll get to your question if it comes
in here and gets on this pile we'll get
to it uh you just stay with us until we
get to your question and we thank you in
advance for doing so Pastor boy if you
would kindly beseech the Lord in our
behalf I would thank you
Father in heaven we come before your
throne with humility
realizing that your ways are much
greater than ours your wisdom far
surpasses ours amen and therefore we
recur to you to ask that you will be
with us to instruct us as we share these
questions and attempt to provide an
answer from your word we ask Lord that
you will Enlighten our minds that you
will bless those who are watching that
their lives might be changed to the good
to the better as a result of this
program amen we pray this in the
precious name of Jesus amen amen and
amen our first question today comes to
us from Charlie there is a preamble to
it and I think I'm going to read that
because it is it is actually a fairly uh
wonderful testimony then comes the
question and uh the Bible says a good
report a good testimony makes the bones
fat so uh we'll read all of this uh just
a few lines and then actual the actual
question comes
uh Charlie rice greetings from Salem
Oregon thank you for letting us know
where you are running from uh Charlie I
thank God for your ministry I've been
watching some TV now for about three
years and I have relearned so much I've
been an Adventist for almost 20 years
but I wandered away from the flock for
many years a few years ago God through
his holy spirit convicted my heart and
we like to hear reports like that amen
broke the chains of bondage and forgave
me of my sins that's a good report amen
leading me back on the straight and
narrow path some TV has been a major
part of of my reconversion experience
and growth and I want to just put a
period there you know we like to hear
that because you know you're you're
preaching you're teaching you're you're
spending time in production it it
encourages us to know that what we are
doing each and every day is of blessing
to you helps you on your Christian
experience so uh we like to get these
reports because it is is a testament to
the moving of the power of the holy
spirit in this ministry that God has
erected this time around I pray that I
may settle into the truth and not waver
we share in that prayer Charlie being
rooted in Christ Jesus that's a good
testimony amen and uh something we'd
like to hear now comes the question
can you please explain elaborate on Mark
chapter 9 that is Mark chapter 9 verse
1. I am pretty sure that I've seen this
covered before on one of your programs
but I I am not sure thanks always and
God bless so Charlie thank you for your
encouragement and thank you for your
question let me read uh Mark 9 1 from
the new King James and then I'll open it
up to you worthy Brethren uh to sort of
tackle it along with me and he said to
them assuredly I say to you that there
are some standing here who will not
taste death till they see the kingdom of
God present with power
Mark chapter 9 and verse 1. of course
the issue is that they're all dead and
did they see Jesus coming in his kingdom
if they're dead and Jesus hasn't come
yet I think that's the gist of the
question yes so how do we answer this
question I think Daniel has some wisdom
on this particular point
yeah so we have the same reference in
Luke chapter 9 verse 27 yes and of
course Mark 9 verse 1 but I think the
most complete account is found in
Matthew beginning with chapter 16 where
we find the context to this statement by
Jesus Christ so this is here in the
context of Jesus is predicting his death
and resurrection and then inviting his
disciples to take up his cross we can
read from verse 21 and onward but then I
went to after Jesus said this I want to
emphasize here verses 27 and 28 for the
son of man will come in the glory of his
father with his angels and then he will
reward each according to his works and
then comes the verse assuredly I say to
you there are some standing here who
shall not taste death till they see the
son of man coming in his kingdom now the
question would be did Jesus give a false
prophecy certainly not we cannot think
that of Jesus so how can we answer this
the answer is just in the next chapter
that we find the Transfiguration on the
mount
and Ellen White says maybe I don't know
if Pastor board has that quote that this
was a a miniature representation of the
coming of the Kingdom because there you
have Jesus you have Elias or Elijah as
representing those who will be alive
when Jesus comes and there is Moses
representing those who will be called
from the graves when Jesus comes so we
see here a miniature representation of
the coming of the kingdom of God
I think the key to verse 28
is the word some some yes because when
Jesus said that he was speaking to the
twelve the 12 were there yes but only
some of them would see this other man
coming in his glory and the very next
chapter tells us who the Samar it says
now after six days Jesus Took Peter
James and John his brother LED them up
on a high mountain by themselves and
then you have the Transfiguration so the
sum are the three that Jesus Took at the
top to the top of the mount because
really the other disciples did not see
the Transfiguration correct and of
course what Jesus meant is that they
would see Jesus as he will come at the
second coming and the description is uh
you know the description is glorious
there it says he was transfigured before
them his face Shone like the sun
Revelation chapter 1 describes Jesus in
the same way and his clothes became
White as the light so that's the way
Jesus is going to appear when he when he
comes yes and so he revealed to the sum
which are the three the way in he which
he was going to come in his kingdom in
the future
well said uh both of you I I like the
part uh that there were two people Moses
and Elijah who were representative of
all of those who will see Christ when he
comes those who will see him not having
tasted death and of course those who are
of fulfillment of first Thessalonians 4
16 who are raised with him
um and um uh uh this idea that it is a
representation of Christ when he he
comes uh really answers that question
quite well anything else you want to add
to that Pastor or Pastor I think the
explanation is quite clear
it's interesting to read you know the
fact that the father speaks to Jesus yes
and he says this is my beloved Son hear
ye him in other words pay attention to
him because in the previous chapter
Jesus had said I'm going to Jerusalem
I'm going to be mistreated I'm going to
die I'm going to resurrect the third day
and Peter says that's not going to
happen to you that doesn't happen to the
Messiah so so the voice says now this is
my son listen to him even though what he
says doesn't appear to be logical to you
at this moment so anyway yeah well said
that it doesn't fulfill your wishes but
it fulfills the wishes of all eternity
of Heaven and Earth right listen to him
and
jettison your own pre Notions of how
this is going to turn out so well done
all right our next one comes from is it
Beverly Benson from Beverly
if almost all of Revelation and and if
you listen to the question part of the
answers in the question by the way if
almost all of Revelation is written in
symbols why do we interpret the vials as
literal because the churches trumpets
and seals all cover the same time period
uh how do we know that the bowls or
vials don't cover these same periods uh
sent from my iPhone so Beverly that's
the question she is wondering about the
vials as opposed to the churches the
trumpets and the seals
now there's actually two questions that
she's asking uh the first question of
course deals with whether the vials are
literal or not and the second question
deals with uh why the seven last plagues
don't cover the same period as the
churches the seals and the trumpets yes
so I think we probably need to take uh
each one and then and try and answer
each one well I think it it is fairly
obvious uh and and most Revelation
Scholars agree the churches trumpets and
seals cover historical time periods
um up until the close of probation the
coming of Christ so and they are
sequential they cover the same time
periods from different aspects but they
are they are historical uh in nature and
have to be understood like that what is
interesting is she says if almost all of
Revelation is written in symbols well
almost all is but not all right right
so we we know that the first serve the
trumpet that trumpets churches and seals
do cover historical time periods but the
vials are a little bit different yeah
the fact is that the Bible itself tells
us that the seven vials are not parallel
to church history
Revelation 15 verse 1 would be the key
verse
um and I see Daniel saying yes because
he had the same text
many times our minds run in the same
track yes all three of us uh it says in
Revelation 15 verse 1 then I saw another
sign in heaven great and marvelous 7
seven angels having the seven last
plagues for in them the wrath of God is
complete yes this is the complete
outpouring of God's Wrath whereas the
trumpet says a third happened to this
and a third you know happened to this uh
this is not uh partial judgments this is
the full manifestation of the wrath of
God and of course uh you know you you
take uh even even the churches the seals
and the trumpets when you get to number
six and number seven you're dealing with
end time events yes because that's
dealing with the last stage of the
church it's dealing with the last stage
of the seals the last stage of the
trumpets but they all actually begin in
Apostolic times according to the
historic stories as principle and then
they are fulfilled in sequence
throughout church history culminating
with end time events yes yes and another
important point is that we have a Bible
principle of interpretation of of not
interpreting something
symbolically and less the little
interpretation doesn't fit the reality
in the case of the plagues
and the whole context of the plagues in
the description at least the first four
gives us indications that these are
literally literal plagues if we see
literal suffering there the men
suffering because of these things
because of these plagues the animals see
life the Earth and and the destruction
of the Earth in the end of time is going
to be quite literal now there is an
aspect here
that in regards to the seven last
plagues and is that not all of them are
literal
because when it comes to number five and
number six for example that deal
specifically with the final fall of the
papacy and the Beast we see that they
are symbolic for example the drawing out
of the Euphrates that is symbolic they
are actually literal expressed exactly
right because but it's very real that
the Waters of Babel and they're going to
church but the waters are multitude
Nations tongues and peoples it's a real
historical event but it's expressed in
in symbolic language for the simple
reason that God wants us to connect this
period with the previous mention of the
Beast and the false prophet and so on so
you know if a different symbolism had
been chosen for plagues five six and
seven people wouldn't have any idea that
it's connected with the dragon the Beast
and the false prophet true so so
everything Louis word says in his book
that whatever is connected to Babylon
since Babylon is a symbolic uh entity in
Revelation then it it uses symbolic
language right but the first four are
not directly connected even though
Babylon is also being affected by these
plagues but the last three are more
directly connected to Babylon and
therefore there is use of symbolic
language but there are literal plagues
yeah and many of these plagues are
similar to what happened in Egypt yes
yes the plague is plagues of Egypt were
very much literal
as bad as things are on the earth now
someone may think well we're undergoing
the plays now no these are still the
beginning of Sorrows of Matthew 24.
um things are going to get much worse
but um uh the world is not undergoing
the complete wrath of God and one of the
things we can we can praise the Lord for
even with the tragedies that are that
are multiplied today they are still
mingled with Mercy amen because the door
of Mercy is still open men and women are
still you know just driving here this
morning I saw a horrific accident on 41
South just a truck had hit a car and and
the car is so mangled that I couldn't
even tell what car what kind of car it
was and I said you know there must be
lots of life there but there are times
when people are in accidents like that
and walk away from that when I was in
college my roommate had a little
Volkswagen that thing rolled down the
side of a mountain and he walked away
from that from that accident so the
mercies of God are still being uh uh
poured out upon men and women because
God is still trying to change Hearts
he's still trying to to resurrect lives
and call people to himself when these
plagues come they come unmingled with
Mercy because those who are to be saved
are saved so this is not there's nothing
Redemptive about this this is the wrath
of God poured out without mixer and
that's made clear in the Three Angels
messages were particularly the third
Angel's message where it says in verse
10 he himself shall also drink of the
wine of the wrath of God which is poured
out full strength full strength which
which literally is without mixture yes
another important thing is that during
the plagues probation has closed and we
know know that because several times in
chapter 16 where the plagues are it says
they did not repent yes see God allows
calamities to happen during church
history in order so that people wake up
and they say you know I need to turn my
life over to the Lord but at this point
just to give one example uh in the fifth
Bowl in verse 11 of chapter 16 it says
they blaspheme the god of Heaven because
of their pains and their source and did
not repent of their deeds and that's
repeated several times in chapter 16. so
at this point there's no repentance no
no just anger just retribution but but
no repentance because those that are
going to be saved are saved those are
going to be lost are lost and there is
no Redemptive aspect to the last right
this is the retributive
wrath of God what's that
all right remedial
[Laughter]
very true very true all right we've got
time for a couple more I do believe what
is the next one is this one from Samson
Simpson Sampson
was was the devil and his angels
cast out of Heaven before the biblical
creation of the Earth or during the
creation of the Earth or immediately
after the creation of the Earth
I wish also to ask emphatically that uh
has been our
that has
I think he's referring our being have
our recreated
that has our being recreated again
because according to Genesis kind of
creation there was some already existing
matter
uh can we connect that to prehistoric
events of the dinosaurs because most of
them
predate the existence of of the first
man Adam Okay so we've got a couple
things to work through here yes yeah
several things yeah the the first the
first question has to do with uh when
Satan was cast out uh of Heaven uh
whether was it before the creation of
this worth or after there's one thing
that we know for sure
and that is that it was the creation of
this Earth and of Adam and Eve that led
to Satan's jealousy of Christ yes uh in
early writings page 145 uh Ellen White
wrote Satan was once an honored angel in
heaven next to Christ his countenance
like those of other Angels was mild and
expressive of Happiness his forehead was
high and Broad showing great
intelligence his form was perfect his
bearing Noble and Majestic
but when God said to his son let us make
man in our image
Satan was jealous of Jesus he wished to
be consulted concerning the formation of
man see man hasn't been formed yet and
because he was not he was filled with
Envy jealousy and hatred he desired to
receive the highest honors in heaven
next to God so he did not Aspire
directly to the throne of the father he
aspired to the position of Christ
because he argued to the angels that
Christ was on the same level with him so
why does the son get special privileges
and why does the father consult him
about creation and he doesn't consult me
that's where the controversy originated
before the creation of this world
precisely so so the Bible picks up the
I I don't want to say argument the
discussion in mainstream should we
should we not should we go ahead yes let
us make man in our own image yes uh and
of course by then Satan has become
disaffected with his own position and of
course Ellen White tells us that God
warned Adam and Eve that Satan had been
cast out so they weren't left alone that
I'm giving you this information so you
can be on your guard so it kind of lets
us know that his his his disaffection
happened prior right to the creation of
Adam and Eve and then he comes to the
Garden precisely afterwards yes comes to
the Earth and temp Seton and Tennessee I
was going to say that the fact that God
warned them already yes in Genesis
chapter 2 verse 16 and 17 shows us that
Lucifer had already fallen
to this earth now
or he had already fallen into sin now
there is a
a verse that we often quote
when we when it comes about when it
comes to Satan's
being cast out of heaven and we use this
verse a lot in evangelism and I believe
it's it's fine it's not something major
when we speak about the Great War in
heaven and Satan being cast out in
verses 7 through 9
here in Revelation chapter 12 verse
uh seven the Bible says and war broke
out in heaven Michael and his angels
fought with the dragon and the dragon
and his Angel spot and they did not
Prevail nor was a place found for them
in heaven and in any more or any longer
so the Great Dragon was cast out that
Serpent of old called the devil and
Satan who deceives the whole world he
was cast out to the Earth and his angels
were cast out with him but here we see
that when he was cast out
it says that
he is the one that deceives the whole
world yes so he had already deceived the
whole world when he was cast out and we
understand this as being cast out of the
sympathies of the Heavenly beings in
heaven at the cross when Jesus overcame
Satan at the cross but actually in the
first verses when we see the dragon
dragging the third part of the stars of
Heaven I would I would apply that to
when he was first cast out of Heaven
before creation but here there is
another war and there is a there is
another defeat of Satan if you will at
the cross
verses seven through nine
and that's what Jesus meant when he said
in John chapter 12 now is the Judgment
of this world now the ruler of this
world will be cast out yes and he was
talking about his death according to
verse 33 so Satan was cast out in two
ways at the cross number one uh in the
sympathies of heavenly beings the mask
was torn off the Heavenly beings were
clear about who Satan really was and
they they understood clearly the person
that he was and secondly he was cast out
as a representative of this world
because Jesus had taken back what he had
taken from Adam yes I think that is a
very important point there was a second
unmasking of Satan uh uh an elohake is
evidence of this that at the cross uh
can we say The Jig was up you know where
there was no more uh illusion as to
Satan's motives what he wanted he had a
chance to get dare say His Hands On
Christ and he used that chance to murder
the the the son of God God so there was
there were no more Illusions in heaven
or on Earth as to what Satan was and he
was unmasked for a second time uh at the
cross yes
already that you know the second
question we have just a couple of
minutes left the second question has to
do with
um a theory called the ruin and
reconstruction Theory the idea that God
created this world and then it was
ruined and then he made he created the
world again but that the world was here
and the matter was already here uh the
fact is that in Ministry of healing
Ellen White has because it's it's he
speaks here that there was already
existing matter when he did supposedly
the second creation which there's no
evidence of that in the Bible Ellen
White wrote in the creation of the earth
God was not indebted to pre-existing
matter yes yes he spake and it was he
commanded and stood fast all things
material or spiritual stood up before
the Lord Jehovah at his voice and were
created for his own purpose the heavens
and all the hosts of them the Earth and
all things therein came into existence
by the breath of his mouth so the idea
that God used pre-existing matter to do
the new creation is not in harmony with
scripture and it's not in harmony with
the spirit of Prophecy either mm-hmm
mm-hmm well said there are any number of
and I'm trying to think of of uh part of
the uh Aztec creation of the world which
which is built on that idea that there
was pre-existing matter God took it
reworked it and started again but of
course that is not that is not in
Hebrews 11 it says that he created
things from from nothing yeah and and
what the what the people who believe in
that say is they translate uh Genesis 1
1 and 2. in uh where it says in the
beginning God created the heavens and
the Earth and the Earth became without
form and void and then God said let
there be light so you have a second
creation but the translation became just
doesn't work yes it's not in the Hebrew
praise the lord well our time has fast
slipped into eternity a lot of men
clothing to wish you both Grace and
peace through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ we'll see you again soon bye bye
and God bless
foreign
[Music]